Carmen Sanchez is an acid attack
Survivor The Assault she suffered nine
years ago at the hands of a former
partner left scars on 70 percent of her
body
this attack left me in the hospital for
eight months it affected half of my face
my neck my chest my arms and legs were
completely damaged after some 64
reconstructive surgeries gottman says
the trauma never fully goes away and
part of that has to do with the fact her
attacker was never arrested activists
say that in many cases attacks like
these go unpunished
as I met other women who were survivors
of this type of violence I realized the
scale of this social problem the first
thing I did was change from being a
victim to an activist
protests calling on the Mexican
Government to do more to curb violence
against women have intensified in recent
years
while attacks on women using acid have
also been documented in other parts of
Latin America activists say the problem
here in Mexico is especially bad
the problem is not only reduced to
attacks with acid and corrosive
substances violence is becoming much
more cruel and extreme and this includes
other types of toxic flammable reactive
and caustic substances women's rights
Advocates argue that this form of
extreme violence is partly rooted in bad
policy given that authorities in Mexico
treat acid attacks the same way as any
other form of assault one thing
activists are pushing for is passage of
a bill currently in the Mexican Congress
which seeks to reclassify acid attacks
as a distinct crime equivalent to
attempted murder if passed the new law
would increase the punishment for
attacks using acid or other corrosive
chemicals with up to 12 years in prison
this is one of many steps necessary
towards creating an integrated see that
will restore some of the rights that
have been taken away from survivors of
this type of violence
though Mexico's government does not keep
an official count of acid attacks
women's rights activists have documented
at least 34 over the last 20 years but
many believe the number of victims to be
far higher Manuel rapalo Al Jazeera
Mexico City